I hear Joe sugg you guys hello this is
so exciting thanks for having me I
watched a lot of your videos and like I
was telling you before it always seems
like your buddies are just around all
the time yeah and it always seems like
somehow one of you gets completely naked
for some reason or another my question
is how many of your friends have you
seen completely naked Joe what the funny
thing is this morning I was I was
vlogging I was trying to scare early
this morning I went ran outside to try
make him jump and he was showering with
the witness completely open straight
away this is kind of a daily basis that
one tip is never to edit your vlogs on a
plane she forget that were a train yeah
you can see the reflection the windows
editing your video where I am bursting
on cash from the shower I think and I
was editing on a plane I didn't realize
there was I think I don't know if it was
a viewer or not but there was a young a
young girl between the seat so that uh
whoops maybe close it's very good sorry
Casper
now you're on planes all the time I feel
like a constant see you and Casper just
taking selfies on planes what's the
weirdest plane experience you've had
recently or like just most memorable Oh
recently I flew into Miami for a YouTube
conference for like Latin America should
be interesting yeah how's he do you know
I mean it was just me and my manager we
flew in and as we were coming into land
we were honestly about from the floor to
the seating away from like touching the
ground all sudden the engines kicked in
again we shot off in the sky again what
and they were like shut her in and like
it was like everything was shaking and I
sort of turn round annoyingly I didn't
get my vlogging camera out and vlog
anyway huh right nowadays my bad I do
that'd be so great thumbnail and title
window I thought this is it that is not
actually my actually gonna die next my
manager is this how I'm gonna go great I
appreciate all that you do for me I just
did didn't I die next and I look to my
left and I thought maybe it's just like
something there's quite a lot it's my
left there's an old couple of holding
hands and I was like this is not helping
at all and I looked down the aisle and I
looked at the air hostess and she seemed
pretty calm but then I realized like
it's their job to look calm right no
that's what I do too is I look to see if
like the the attendants on the plane
when they're panicked that's when I pass
yeah yeah but that's all apparently
that's all if you'd like if you are
gonna you know
fashioned to see you have to still still
play a job later my okay so you're not
getting paid unless you get those - yeah
but but then they said it's a an
operational fault not a technical fault
so they can relax because their parents
it's like there was another plane that
pulled out in front of us on the runway
last minute oh wow I've got a friend
who's an air hostess and she said that
oh yeah it happens all the time
Oh interest yeah so I thought I honestly
thought that was it I'm in Miami of all
places and I haven't even seen Miami
ironically I was saying to my man Joyce
and she was saying how she hates landing
as a landings like the best billet
nothing could go wrong when you land so
I hate taking off that's the worst
because always think it's gonna take off
and you said in your head and well you
don't have any fuel turns out yeah yeah
well I knew I forgot something but then
as I said our landings fine that's when
we shut off again so I completely jinx
it your manager is still your manager
even after you put a scream that you
didn't want to die
yeah like you of all people I'm sorry
gotta bring it closer together are there
things that are kind of like an extreme
like goals dreams in a crazy world you
would love to make a clothing line have
a breed a new breed of dog that we could
buy all right I mean I just created a
goal for myself let me write this down
recently last year I got to UM be a
voice in the new spongebob film yeah in
the probably annoyingly in the Prairie
the British version sorry us but the I
loved doing I love pairing on voices and
making stupid voices um you do a lot of
voice-over in a lot of your video yes
your vlogs and Jeff and I think it's
really it's really impressive yeah I
love like imitating people's voices
uh-huh so I am goals for me to be to
Ebert be a voice in a like a Pixar film
what a Disney film what I like a
whatever that may be or even like the
next whatever the next kind of Family
Guy is yeah something sort of sort of
animated sitcom kind I think I'd love to
do a voice in that is there someone that
you impersonate the best that's in your
like top um ooh everyone loves my outfi
my outfit I hear you're Alfie when it's
funny is when he's logging uh any hey
tiger he's like hi
guys uh I'm going to bed now suppose I
could say goodnight to Nala I'm upset
he's already gone to sleep ah she
finished leap at 7:00 show her saying I
love you guys so much
thumbs up if you enjoyed this vlog my
gosh I love you guys so much sorry Alfie
imitation is the highest form of
flattery oh yeah I fully believe it
that's amazing I always sounds like he's
been talking for six years and that his
voice is barely hanging on
now you just put that out into the
universe I thought I think so now maybe
the Pixar people these are the huge fans
of this podcast
oh good don't be getting in touch with
you ASAP and every now and then when
Casper's away sneak into his bathroom
and I like some candles around the bath
I know this is a split yeah I know it's
really bad